el agonizante calor deja víctimas y
daños
lisboa contabilizado mil 63 muertes
entre el 7 al 18 de julio en semanas
donde las temperaturas superaron los 40
grados centígrados
aviv los datos del sistema de registro
de defunciones muestran que hay un
aumento de la mortalidad y en particular
entre los grupos de mayor edad que
corresponde cada año 870 muertes más en
comparación con el año anterior
además los bomberos buscan controlar las
voraces llamas en portugal en españa'
las conflagraciones llegaron a zonas
residenciales y en reino unido- hay
casas ardiendo en londres
con las altas temperaturas en el
suroeste de europa las ideas para tratar
de sobrellevar el calor no cesan los
británicos escaparon las ciudades
costeras para refrescarse en un intento
de huir del día más caluroso registrado
en la historia de reino unido con 40
grados centígrados y en medio de una
alerta de emergencia nacional las
fuentes de agua que acompañan a la torre
eiffel en parís se convirtieron en
piscinas públicas en donde locales y
turistas buscaron escapar del intenso
sol por suerte tenemos esta fuente si no
estaríamos fritos estamos empapados pero
es realmente refrescante mientras tanto
en fráncfort la capital financiera de
alemania los trabajadores que no pueden
dejar su oficina para ir a la playa
salieron a beber agua de las fuentes
públicas de la ciudad allí las
temperaturas ya alcanzaron los 38 grados
centígrados en bélgica cuando el
instituto real de meteorología registró
temperaturas de 37 a 7 grados algunos
empleados de una red de asilos de
adultos mayores encontraron en una
piscina infantil la solución para ayudar
a sus pacientes a lidiar con el calor
este lunes la nasa publicó una imagen
satelital que muestra las intensas
temperaturas que desde julio afectar
principalmente a europa áfrica y asia
expertos y científicos de la
organización mundial de la salud han
advertido que el panorama climático
incluso puede empeorar en las próximas
semanas